as far as GM knew about the defect in
the ignition switches as far back as
2001 thirteen years before the recall
correct the yes or no will work the
investigation will tell us that you
don't know when GM knew about the defect
I I will take a look at tab seven in
your notebook miss burrow this is a GM
document and what this GM document talks
about is this switch it says teardown
evaluation on the switch revealed two
causes of failure low contact force and
low detent plunger force do you
recognize that document ma'am this is
the first I've seen this documented some
questions are so important that the way
you answer them will have a huge
outsized impact on your career Mary
Barra is a GSB grad she's an alum and
she'll have been CEO General Motors for
three months before she was called to
testify in Congress like we just saw and
their performance they're really defined
has defined her brand as CEO my name is
Steve Grossman and we're here to talk to
you today about what we call extreme QA
and I want to try and convince you guys
that that this situation is something
important to think about now and that
all of us over the next few years will
face situations where we answer
questions in public and how we answer
those questions is really going to
define our careers as well and the same
techniques that apply in front of all
the lights and hot TV lights and cameras
and Congress equally apply in our
careers right away we're also going to
ask you guys ask two things of you guys
the first is that you find a resource
for how to address these situations and
the second is that you you actually
invest the time and practicing these
techniques now because it takes time to
develop muscle memory which is really
what you're going to be relying on when
down the road in your career we're in
the same situation that Mary Barra was
in talking about resources the best one
that we found is a book called in the
line of fire by Jerry Weisman Jerry was
a producer for 60 minutes so he
has a lot of experience asking tough
questions and he has a career now
advising CEOs as they prepare to take
their company's public on how to answer
the toughest questions during an IPO
Roadshow he also the book is highly
recommended by some really important
people so don't don't just take our word
for it so Jerry uses the analogy that
high-stakes QA is a martial art a
martial art that has four key components
we're going to dissect those components
one at a time
and chunsu is going to start at the
logical beginning with the importance of
preparation on August 24th of 2008
governor Sarah Palin was nominated as a
first female candidate of Republican
party for Vice President of the United
States a poll taken right after her
nomination she was more popular than
either Brock Obama or John McCain it was
truly the inflection point in her career
however journalists and critics kept
asking this one question let me start by
asking you a question that I asked John
McCain about you and it is really the
central question can you look the
country in the eye and say I have the
experience and I have the ability to be
not just vice president but perhaps
president of the United States of
America when I asked John McCain about
your national security credentials he
cited the fact that you have commanded
the Alaskan National Guard and that
Alaska is close to Russia are those
sufficient credentials
they kept asking one this question which
was about her foreign policy credentials
after her first interview with Charlie
Gibson she was soon scheduled to have
another interview another primetime TV
interview with Katie Couric incidentally
it was rumored that she refused to have
preparation due to invite that went on
within the McCain's campaign and when
Katie asked her about her foreign policy
credentials it wasn't the first time she
was asked and if anybody if there's a
one question that anybody could have
thought of that evening was that was it
she didn't prepare for it and now let's
watch what happened you've cited
Alaska's proximity to Russia as part of
your foreign policy experience what did
you mean by that that Alaska has a very
narrow maritime border between a foreign
country Russia and on our other side the
land boundary that we have with Canada
it's funny that a comment like that was
kind of made to Karen I don't know you
know monitors yeah macht I guess that's
the word yeah it was devastating
devastating to her image devastating to
her Republican Party campaign they never
recovered from it
preparation perhaps is the most
important thing we can do to do well in
answering the question that will define
our career at GSP we talk about role
playing throughout many classes
Jerry Weisman in his book uses this term
murder board approach which takes one
step further first you want to find a
setting that is more similar to the
situation that you will be situated in
so from room orientation to lightning
and so on second you want to find
someone who's willing to ask you a
question in a way that is from ordinary
to the nest as possible
and lastly you want to practice over and
over again it's like practicing volley
compartment you're tensing now let me
turn it over to Peter who's going to
talk about specific techniques to use
once you are situated in the extreme to
exit all right
so you've done your homework you are
well-prepared in the other presentation
memorize so now what do you do when you
step it in the arena and the volley of
difficult questions comes your way it's
easy to get set back on your heels but
the important thing is for you to
re-engage and take control of the
situation there are three ways that we
say you can do that and we've picked up
from Wiseman's book the first is to
always maintain self-control the second
is to establish your self-defense and
the third is to give a balanced answer
we saw on the Palin questions that she
did none of these very well and I'd like
to show you another example and this is
in 1987 with Colonel Oliver North in the
iran-contra testimony and you'll see
that he answers these questions much
differently and we think with much more
effective answers she works on the phone
with the Israelis leading
shred documents okay on occasion
weren't you going through your files to
get rid of embarrassing documents
embarrassing no documents that would
compromise the national security of the
United States documents that would put
lives at risk
documents that would demonstrate a
covert action the US direction and
control and and relationship to it yes I
can I think oh I'm not embarrassed to be
here counsel so then you can notice the
difference between the two responses
there and contrast so the first thing
that Colonel North does is he maintains
his self-control so he answers with
conviction and most importantly he
doesn't get angry most people's
immediate response is to give an answer
to shoot it back so ranee jerk response
you're prepared now I'm going to give an
answer but oftentimes its ill-prepared
and doesn't give the message that you
intended to
so Colonel North in this case doesn't
get angry if he had you have alienated
his audience he would have conveyed a
sense of evasive nests or defensive
Necedah alienate your audience but you
can really distort your message so once
you maintain your self-control is the
time to give an answer just yet
we'd say no the second thing is to
establish your self-defense so you've
been knocked back on your heels and this
is a time where you re engage with your
audience and take control of the
situation again the trick here is to
clarify the question and to rephrase it
not restate it word by word but
paraphrase it take a negative question
turn it around strip out the negative
words and the connotations and turn into
a question that you're prepared to
answer for the positive spin and a
positive answer you'll see in that in
Colonel Morris testimony that you took a
question about shredding documents and
instead turn that around and gave an
answer which is a statement on values
not his actions for shredding documents
so finally when you get to the but to
the point where you've prepared yourself
to actually give the answer for the
question you've rephrased it the trick
here is to answer the question directly
and take it head-on so if you've
established your presence your backing
and choose your words carefully at this
point as I haven't had the pleasure of
testifying in front of Congress I hope
none of us do
for negative things but I have worked
with congressional staffers and
congressional staffers in the media have
long term memories they pay attention to
the words you say those words have
meanings and most importantly your
integrity is something that they won't
forget so when you think about the words
you stay maintain your self-control
establish your defense and give a
balanced answer that most importantly is
straightforward and honest and with
conviction so that we've talked about
the preparation we've talked about how
to how to give the answer and I'll turn
it over to it to wrap up the
conversation thanks Peter so what does
this mean for all of us as Stanford
grads interested in business so
hopefully we're not testifying in front
of Congress in the next few years but
we're all going to be in plenty of
high-stakes meetings we might be
pitching a document for a consulting gig
we might be pitching an investment or we
might just be asked to discuss what
we've been working on on a conference
call but what we're saying here is it is
we need to establish good performance
and answering tough questions because
those people asking the questions will
be influential members of determining
your career trajectory and as you
perform well in your early career it
will help reinforce a successful career
in the future so with those four things
of preparation self control self defense
and balance let's translate it into what
that means for us take the time to
prepare for meetings memorize the facts
know who's going to be in the room and
know what questions they might ask avoid
getting defensive and flustered we're
early in our careers we are already
starting from behind we don't want to
give any more reason to be look look
immature and look like we're not
credible clarify questions you don't
want to answer the wrong question make
sure you know what question you're
answering and make sure they know what
it is
and don't make up an answer don't don't
try to be us an answer as they say if
you don't know tell them you're going to
get back to them
it's they'll get caught on to the wrong
answer the second you give it so don't
take that risk and now let's practice
some ourselves we have we've talked
about tough QA so let's give you guys
the opportunity to see how we do on it